سابدا من اخر خبر اوردته قبل قليل وهو رصد
فريق الجزيره على حدود قطاع غزه لهذه
المنطقه العازله والتدمير الكبير الذي
تقوم به قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عمق
تقريبا 2 م في عمق قطاع غزه والان الحديث
عن المناطق الشماليه لكن دعونا نبدا من
هذه المنطقه التي كنا نتحدث عنها هذا هو
معبر المنطار كارني المنطار المغلق بطبيعه
الحال منذ عام 2007 تقريبا بعد فوز حركه
حماس بانتخابات التشريع وتشكيلها الحكومه
ولكن الذي يجري الان في هذه المنطقه هو
تدمير كبير بعمق تقريبا 2 م بهذا الشكل
تقريبا بين كيلو ونصف الى 2 كم المباني
التي شاهدناها تدمر قبل قليل في الصوره في
هذه المنطقه تقريبا وتم الحديث عن حوالي
56 مبنى دمرت بشكل كامل في وقت واحد كما
شاهدنا في مقطع الفيديو الذي شاهدناه قبل
قليل الذي يقوم به الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الان مدفعيته المرابطه في في هذه المناطق
وطيرانه الذي لا يغيب عن سماء قطاع غزه
يقوم بتدمير كل هذه المناطق الحدوديه داخل
قطاع غزه بعمق تقريبا 2 م لتشكيل منطقه
عازله لتكون هذه المنطقه العازله هذا مثال
طبعا هذه المنطقه العازله هذه المنطقه
العازله ستكون ب بما كما قالت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه ستكون هي مركز القوات
الهجوميه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي لن يعود
سكان قطاع غزه الذين يسكنون في هذه
المنطقه نتحدث عن الاطراف الشرقيه لمدينه
غزه الشجاعيه وحي التفاح وكل هذه المناطق
لن يعودوا الى منازلهم بعد هذا التدمير
هذا الامر ينسحب ايضا على المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه نتحدث عن بيت حنون
ونتحدث عن بيت لاهيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن هذه
المناطق فنحن نتحدث عن هذه المسافات
والمساحات الكبيره بشكل عام نتحدث عن عمق
2 م داخل قطاع غزه على طول الحدود او طول
السياج الفاصل عن نتحدث عن 60 كيلو هذا
يعني اننا تحدث عن حوالي 120 م مربع يسعى
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى تدميرها بشكل
كامل وجعلها مناطق غير قابله للسكن بل
ومناطق عسكريه لقواته لمنع دخول او منع
تكرار سيناريو عام سيناريو السابع من
اكتوبر بدخول المقاومه الفلسطينيه
للمستوطنات الاسرائيليه او ما يعرف
بمستوطنات غلاف غزه اذا هذا المشروع الاهم
الذي الان يطرح على الطاوله والذي يجري
تنفيذه كما يبدو من مراقبه فريق الجزيره
ال الواقف هناك في غلاف غزه تدمير كامل
لعمق حوالي 2 م تدمير كل المنازل وكل
المباني هذا الامر يتزامن مع العمليات
العسكريه التي لا تتوقف سواء من قصف قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكل مناطق قطاع غزه
او لعمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
تتركز في منطقتين رئيسيتين هما منطقتا
التوغل البري الاسرائيلي نتحدث بدرجه
اساسيه عن منطقه خان يونس في المنطقه
الجنوبيه
نعلم ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي توغل في
خانيونس من المنطقه الشرقيه صحيح انه وصل
من المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه وهو الان على
مشارف مدينه خانيونس التي يسعى للدخول
اليها باعتبارها وفق ادعائه باعتبارها
مركز عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكتائب
القسام وسرايا القدس تقول كتائب القسام
وتقول سرايا القدس بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تضرب القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة الشماليه الشرقيه عندما نتحدث عن
المنطقه الشرقيه من خانيونس نتحدث عن بنس
هيلا و عبسان المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من
خانيونس نتحدث عن الزنه ولكن اذا ما قارنا
العمليات العسكريه في خانيونس للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولجيش الاحتلال في خانيونس
والمنطقه الشماليه في الساعات 48 الماضيه
تقريبا هناك انخفاض نسبي في معارك خان
يونس مقارنه في المعارك التي تجري في شمال
قطاع غزه بالذهاب الى معارك شمال قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات ال 48 الماضيه كان هناك ضغط
كبير على محاور التوغل في في احياء مدينه
غزه عندما نتحدث عن احياء مدينه غزه نتحدث
عن حي الدرج نتحدث عن حي التفاح حي الرمال
الذي دمر فيه القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
دمرت حيا كاملا داخل الرمال هي محيط مسجد
فلسطين خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه قصف
عنيف على هذه المناطق ولكن في المقابل
مقاومه شرسه تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه
كتابه القسام ورائ القدس بانها توقع خسائر
واضحه في قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتوغلة
للاحياء الشماليه بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه
التي لا تزال تضرب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي رغم انها مدمره بشكل شبه كامل
هذه